[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 107 q and a
sorry for the long pause that was a
technical difficulty entirely outside of
our control
but here we're here we are we are ready
here we are taking back control
a modicum of control
i don't know how much that is but i
think it's like a smidge it's a smidge
yes it's uh it's it's more than an
omicron
wow all right um
yep i can live with that okay
um
chipping away at the narrative requires
discomfort one way is to stop doing
things that serve no purpose except to
feed the narrative and people's neuroses
like wearing a mask outside be kind but
firm takes courage but creates courage
in others months ago in phoenix a few
stopped masking and now masks are rare
i think this is true for some things and
won't work for some others right and i
mean i do think the question of outdoor
masking
has for us always been so obvious and
straightforward that um i think i may
have mentioned
um
i don't know when it would have been
at some point uh probably pre-vaccine
stuff so maybe like
14 months ago or so i was walking in
some park that i love
with wide paths
you can easily stay away from people and
some woman with a mask
yelled
in my direction
that's someone behind me who was also
masked thank you for wearing a mask like
well that was not only not direct to me
but clearly passive aggressive and
obnoxious and uh you know i thought
about trying to engage her and it's like
no i'm just i refuse to wear a mask
outside we do still wear masks inside as
we are um
supposedly required to in the state of
oregon i would say we wear them inside
when required
yeah we wear masks inside when when
required
two we are beginning to hear uh tales of
outside
in other areas in oregon especially just
even even really just outside of
portland um some places not um not
requiring them
but the signs on every store here is
accord you know according to the
governor's orders everyone must be
masked to come inside the store
yeah but
i think there is a question here because
um
as we've mentioned before the evidence
that cloth masks work is extremely thin
and the evidence that others
other masks work
is
dependent on them being worn
in a particular way and the chances that
this is actually
a place where
um
you know it makes sense to have this
kind of uh
authoritarianism is pretty low so the
question is
i know that personally
i wear them when required to
because i am not interested in sending a
signal to my
fellow citizens that i am defecting on
them that i am in any way callous about
their well-being i would absolutely give
the middle finger to the authorities
that require these things when it
obviously isn't about health or they're
so inept that they don't know
you know that they should be telling you
uh go outside and delight in the fact
that you don't need a mask there so the
point is but there but i i can hear the
argument from some people that will say
um
these are the same people who think that
you are defecting on them by not
becoming vaccinated right therefore you
know how how is this any different well
because
the point is
we are being dragged into a signal
the signal of the mask it is the signal
of a cult
i don't wish to broadcast that signal at
all
now my vaccination status is nobody's
business really now again there are
circumstances in which a particular
disease with particular public health
authorities and a particular vaccine
could justify a mandate so i'm not
opting out on
that but i guess my point is
because the vaccine status is not
obvious anywhere
this is a much more ambiguous thing but
well so in in california in oregon in
washington uh you have to wear masks to
go into into retail businesses
regardless of your vaccination status in
california and one or two other states i
think at this point apparently the
signage and the rules are people who are
vaccinated don't have to wear masks
inside
and um and
by and large we hear they don't check
but you know they could right and
um i guess i i
i'm not
i don't see
the level of difference that you do
between these two things even as i
continue
to
you know i continue to behave the way i
have from the beginning i put on the
mask at the last possible moment before
going in and rip it off as soon as i
leave and get some dirty looks from
people because you know
you're still close to the store how
could you be unmasked but you know
whereas the most of the country at this
point isn't having to wear masks at all
and they're you know so
masks these masks the way that they are
being employed and the kinds of mass
that people are wearing are very much
like these vaccines in that they
apparently aren't doing the job that
we're being told they do they are
signifiers of compliance
but they are uh inaccurate signifiers of
uh health protection yes they are
signifiers of compliance and in fact
there are signifiers of compliance with
nonsensical health advice right and um i
would point people i haven't been
fully through it yet but people should
look at
chris martinson's recent interview on um
mass formation and the idea that
actually the
nonsensicalness of the rituals is a
feature not a bug
but anyway the point i would make is we
are actually somewhere else the the
conundrum
of what to do about the mask or um more
to the point the vaccine mandates
is in some ways not well addressed by us
at all
it really needs to be addressed by
people who
have been compliant
right in effect what we need is for
people to recognize that the mandates
themselves are
a breach of our social contract with
each other as we discussed uh in the
first part of the podcast
and the point is um
if i was to
go to a store
right let's say
you know the store said that whites only
right
i'm not going in that store
right it doesn't matter that i may
technically qualify i'm not going in
that store because i don't respect it
now if the government issued a mandate
that said actually we need to segregate
for whatever reason so you know blank
and black you know on thursdays these
stores will be whites only so
the only thing that was happening is the
store was complying i'm still not going
into the damn store right and so i think
the point is the rebellion
has to occur against the mandates and it
should unify those of us who are
unvaccinated with those of us who are
vaccinated because clearly the
circumstances does not justify this and
we are being segregated from each other
for reasons that have not been shared
with us and so the point is this is all
immoral you're wrecking our civilization
and you don't have a right to do it so
none of us are going to participate
right that's the answer to this and if
you know the 30 of people who actually
believe this garbage and you know
haven't noticed all of the paradoxes if
those 30 are still gonna participate
fine but you know
they can't they're not a civilization
yeah they're not
um
i'm still i can't remember if i talked
about this on air a week or two or three
or eight or something ago but um
you know one of the things i loved most
about moving to portland was the
prospect of live theater which i've
always always loved and my parents lived
in london for many years every time i'd
visit we we'd see a lot and
i grew up in la seeing a certain amount
and there was a little bit in ann arbor
and we lived there but there's none in
olympia
so i went many many years without
basically having access to much and we
had
we had been seeing live theater and when
covet hit and the tickets that i had
bought
um
you know disappeared into thin air
um
i i said to the theaters in question um
hold on to my you know because they were
desperate and we were i felt so so bad
for for the artists and the other other
live
the people who were doing work that
required that you'd be live in person
with people
but especially the artists and musicians
and such
and said you know hold on to my money
until until you can perform again and
then and then i hope to you know use i
hope to come back and be in person and
they're finally opening up
but it's
they aren't saying you can't come if
you're not vaccinated but they are
saying proof of vaccine or uh
a negative test within some number of
hours and
that means that technically we could we
could go but i i guess
for me i felt like
i was i was one of the staunchest
supporters of and i
will remain
of the creators whose work depends on
being in person with people because we
all need that we all need again to
reclaim our sense of collective joy and
be together in person experiencing
something collectively
and it's those organizations that went
the most woke the fastest during you
know in the aftermath of george floyd
and that have now been you know most
eager to go with medically woke
pronouncements in some places i've heard
that you know you can't even do a
negative test um but frankly the oh yeah
all you have to do is do a negative test
really for all four of us for like in
you know in what time frame and
you know [ __ ] you
frankly yeah well no
no
no i think this is exactly right and
the
the problem is
i don't want to do anything
that signals that i believe in the
fiction i also don't want to signal that
i ever thought kobit wasn't serious or
was itself a fiction right the point is
it was a serious disease we now know a
lot about how to treat it there are
certain people who are blocking our
access to the things which would be
useful in that battle and forcing us to
do things that are
pointless and then also blocking us from
joyous human experience right and so you
know
let's put it this way these people
have the equivalent of
an emblem like nike's swoosh right it is
the mask
and they are
causing even those of us who detest them
to broadcast their advertisement and to
signal that we are compliant with the
such and such and so okay maybe you
don't have to be vaccinated but then
you're going to need a test and the
point is
this is all predicated on the idea that
you need protection from me right i
think the opposite is more likely to be
true yeah and
in fact there's a question to that
effect here
you can keep let me just see if i can
anyway i think the point is look
the time
they're vaccinating children with a
vaccine that does not
aid children they are vaccinating
against them
against a disease that does not harm
healthy children
and they are vaccinating with a
a vaccine that even if you granted them
everything we know nothing about its
long-term implications which matters
more for children because they have
longer lives ahead of them right when
you then add in what we do know about
growth phase and so injury may proceed
faster right depending on what kind of
injury it is obviously not in the
children's interest as far as we can
tell compare the disease to the vaccine
obviously not in the children's interest
therefore it is immoral so the point is
that's the people whose
brand we're now broadcasting with our
masks and who's fiction about who's
dangerous to whom we're going to signal
that we accept by you know ponying up a
test that says that we are in fact free
of covid no the fact is
we know how to deal with this disease
it's now manageable right the tests are
crap the vaccines are crap your
indicator of compliance is just that
because the indicators themselves are
demonstrably crap demonstrably crap and
and bad for people and enough already
and so the point is yeah somehow what i
want what i want to figure out
is some way to broadcast
i am no longer putting up with this [ __ ]
without broadcasting i don't take you my
fellow citizens health seriously because
i do take that seriously but i do not
take these authorities these authorities
need to be taken seriously in a very
different way they are they are a menace
to civilization and they need to be
removed yesterday so that we can get
something like a proper response and get
back to a functional civilization you
know you can't turn it upside down over
myths
watch them well yeah watch them
uh can you steal man both sides of the
following argument if and i'm not sure
exactly what that means
if vaccines work is claimed why would
the vax have to worry about the unboxed
so i'm not sure what steel mining both
sides of that um
means um but
uh if vaccines work as claimed why would
the vax have to worry about the unboxed
yeah i hate to do their goddamn work for
them right
the artist they're not going to do it
for themselves well they're not going to
do it for themselves and they're not
frankly capable of it or
it's not their area they've created
arguments that are
indefensible at some level but you're
about to reveal to us just
well the thing is
tiny way in which the defense let's put
it this way you you know
this is a
this is a garbage
as a product this is garbage it may be a
brilliant prototype but it's not you
know it's not up to snuff for
vaccinating hundreds of millions let
alone billions of people right it
doesn't prevent the transmission of
disease it doesn't prevent you
um from contracting the disease now it
may have
an implication for how likely you are to
contract it and therefore it may be like
a kind of viscosity that changes for a
moment
yeah for a moment in time well i mean
you know
why
are we forced to accept this very small
improvement in the pandemic that
pandemic that comes from
these vaccines preventing a certain
number of cases without also being
able to talk about the increased
vulnerability that comes as you're
developing the immunity
so the point is
when did net go out the window right
it's a net calculation sorry it just is
and that has a meaning and it's very
precise and
um everything but net
it's everything but net that's that's
beautiful i love that it's everything
but net
and the fact is we have the goddamn
tools right this isn't that hard um you
know we have uh
relative uh risk reduction rather than
absolute risk reduction yeah we have all
caused mortality rather than you know
cherry-picked claims about
particular causation and we have number
needed to treat
these are the objective uninflected ways
that you measure how valuable the thing
is and compare it to its alternative and
[Music]
they're not even pretending so
um so but i mean i i haven't heard in
this the steel man of
vaccines if vaccines are what they claim
why would the vacs have to worry about
the unboxed because
because i don't because these super
leaky vaccines
prevent some disease probably and so
some disease probably means that if
you've been injected with a super weak
vaccine when we say they don't prevent
transmission and they may prevent a
little bit of transmission yeah because
if really if all they do
is reduce your likelihood having been
vaccinated of getting the disease by
some small amount for some short amount
of time
um then there's no reason for the
vaccinated
to care well
no okay so if the vaccines work as
advertised
then all of the unvaccinated are
completely unprepared for coping right
like this is this is a landscape in
which there are no treatments except for
those that have just been developed by
pharmaceutical companies completely
unprepared and therefore there's this
large amount of circulating virus that
would be
less amount of circulating virus if um
that would then prevent
that uh the breakthrough cases that
happen among the vaccinated right i
guess i guess that's the steel man
that's the steel yeah and then the
problem is you have to decide how
serious a disease would have to be
in the absence of any treatment how
serious once you have treatments that
work how serious it would have to be to
justify you know forced vaccination you
know you wouldn't force vaccinate over a
cold i'm not saying this is a cold but
the point is there's some line below
which you wouldn't consider doing this
even if you could prevent a certain
amount of disease yeah um and then
there's some line above which maybe you
would consider it and
the point is we never had that
discussion so we know this isn't about
that yeah um
um
i will say
i just so uh matthew crawford's rounding
the earth newsletter on sub stack is
excellent we've talked about it before
and
highly recommend it um
in
today i think or 12 hours ago he posted
this systemic vaccine efficacy part four
consistency i think this is where um
i can't remember exactly where oh
now this this whole piece is excellent
but here he says in a complex system
consistency is the best charge of a
hypothesis
let us consider the two competing
hypotheses hypothesis one the very first
mrna vaccines and other copa 19 vaccines
are all the first several dozen vaccines
to ever work on any
coronavirus versus hypothesis two the
copa 19 vaccines mrna and others have no
substantial efficacy but kill and injury
lots of people
and he then
work you know
talks through and i can't find at the
moment it's it's worth reading the whole
post
among other things it's not like people
haven't been trying for a very long time
to make vaccines of any sort traditional
non-traditional new old whatever against
coronaviruses
and um and obviously the first time that
works will be a moment in time yeah and
so you can't be surprised every time it
happens like well why now well it had to
be some time um but
the the number of those things that have
converged on this one well why now had
to be sometime why this one well it had
to be something like all of these things
point like
every one of those improbable events
compounds with the number with with each
additional and powerful event that you
add to the situation yeah and that's
basically the argument that he's making
here well yeah so it uh it fits with my
saying uh
that epicycles are back right that's
really the point is that somehow we have
completely lost our obligation to
parsimony yeah here yes in service of
something that again has not been
explained to us yep
uh here are a couple comments that you
are sure to love
i've been using jab almost from the
beginning as a pejorative
and
fouchy lies in promoting the mainstream
cover narrative he tries to sound
sophisticated but it's just fiber jabber
jibber jabber
yeah yeah
okay
i know you're getting sick of these
questions but how long does the body
produce spike after vaccine thank you
both
well there's a question of how long it
produces there's a question of how long
it persists and there's a question about
something prion like
um spell that third thing out
so prions producing something prion
prion like a prion-like phenomenon a pro
oh okay
i'm not saying listening initiating a
process that is i'm not saying there is
this thing what i'm saying is it is
within the range of plausibility so that
if you say well the spike's gone by
number of days weeks hours
um that doesn't necessarily answer the
question of how long the effective
molecular echo of spike persists let me
also say that even within that one of
the three things that you uh discussed
what i what i never hear in these
discussions except on places like
rounding the earth and from chris
martinson and um and and such is
is the number that the that pfizer
whoever is produced is that
is that the mean and what's the variance
what was the sample size like none of
the sort of basic parameters of a
statistical understanding of a
population such that if you know i i
don't actually know any idea what the
numbers are supposed to be here um but
so i'm going to make something up here
okay well the you know the body produces
the spike for two months after the
vaccine because that's your body you
know totally making that number up okay
but is that two months with a range of
zero months which is to say it never
produces anything at all too infinitely
because there are some people in whom
we've continued to measure it where
there's still spike after
eight months at this point or a year and
a half or a year i guess
um or is that like two months
plus or minus a week right like you know
how tight are these tolerances and and
is that variable by
uh did they i always feel like this is
the wrong word but did they aspirate
when they gave the vaccine such that it
actually went to the place it was
supposed to go to or immediately started
spreading throughout the body you know
and and
which of these answers are contingent on
which of those other truths means that a
simple answer is almost impossible to
arrive at right and um
add to the complexity that we've got
this question in parallel with the
disease itself
so there's a lot that we could say about
natural immunity and its advantages over
vaccines if we could be certain that the
spike protein produced by the disease
itself was easily managed and was uh
ephemeral right um right so anyway
we can't say that so you're three so i
stopped you after talking about the one
how long is it being produced that is to
say how long are mrnas being uh
translated into protein right
there's uh how long does it persist once
you get these proteins how long do they
circulate around okay and then there's
the prion effect which is how long does
a consequence a molecular consequence of
this particular protein floating around
trigger changes in other proteins and
i'm not saying it does at all it may not
right but it can it could it could it's
yeah
and there are intimations that spike may
have some of these effects so i'm just
saying it's an open possibility
so
um
i don't think we know the answer i do
think it's likely to be highly variable
i've seen very frightening things about
spike being detectable
way after somebody's encounter with the
vaccines um
how good is that how much is this a
question of a amplification protocol
that's so sensitive who knows all of
these things are you know welcome to
complex systems right there are a lot of
ways these things can go wrong
there's also
potentially i guess issues of
molecular mimicry triggering tests uh
inappropriately
so anyway there's a world of complexity
here that could be upending any proper
analysis but i do think
spike is a very interesting protein and
a very dangerous one
i don't think the spike from the vaccine
every time this has been accused of
being false people who know look at it
and they say no spike protein is
cytotoxic we don't have any reason to
believe the spike protein produced by
the vaccines is not cytotoxic what we
may lack is evidence you know
affirmative evidence but
but the point is you would assume based
on the fact that natural spike protein
is toxic
um that so is the spike protein from the
vaccines and indeed there's some there's
some suggestion that it's that it
produces worse effects
right um
but there's the other issue of
the interaction of the body
with
the cells that have been transfected
right so this is i don't know how to
take what i think i know from biology
and translate it into something that
people can hear but when you get
sick with an infection infection gets
into a cell it spreads between cells
as the immune system is ratcheting up
to uh challenge it right that has a kind
of locality to it the cells it is likely
to transfect are to in fact are nearby
not all of them it could move long
distances but
there's a general pattern of locality
and this pattern of locality
incidentally is an argument against the
vaccines because we vaccinate you in the
arm and you get sick in the lungs right
and so the point is
well you get sick in the um the
respiratory tract and the point is that
actually the immune system has this as a
dimension you tend to get immunity where
you tend to get sick because that's
where you got challenged and your immune
system learns the pattern but where it
develops there which reproduces the
pattern of immunity where it is most
needed
okay so
when we
get one of these vaccines
and it circulates around
how many cells it infects it's not
doesn't even infect because it's not a
it's not a a
virus that has been attenuated what it
is is a molecular package that sticks to
human cells and causes the thing inside
to get injected in right then it starts
getting transcribed and so the thing is
any cell it sticks to can start making
this protein which means this protein
can start showing up anywhere that the
vaccine got to exactly and so that is a
very different thing than you have an
infection the patch of cells in your
lung or your sinuses or something and
the immune system challenged it and did
away with it so the question is
we think we know in general what happens
when you get a viral infection of cells
right
ultimately the cells that are producing
virus are targeted
by the immune system and destroyed
they no longer produce virus at that
point
when
a cell that isn't infected by a virus
starts producing this protein on behalf
of
big pharma
right
then
those cells my guess would be they get
destroyed as if they were affected so
now you've got cells
randomly all over the body
being destroyed and to the extent that
they are properly destroyed then maybe
it's no different than the
the virus itself
right
or the fact that you have this transient
signal
right you get a transcript an mrna
transcript into a cell which then
results in that cell making this protein
maybe that's not enough to get that
cell destroyed and then is it just
latent
right might it start producing spike
again later i'm not saying
that this suggests an answer to the
question what i'm suggesting is welcome
to complex systems you've you've
intervened so the thing is that an
ordinary vaccine is very elegant with
respect to how it interfaces with the
system it basically just primes the
system with information that it
ordinarily couldn't get without an
encounter with a pathogen right in this
case you are borrowing cellular
machinery to manufacture
the
informational particle super clever like
you know it's it's brilliant potentially
but you know who knows what effects it
has now of course some vaccines
attenuated virus vaccines actually go
through a process of infection with
something that doesn't cause disease or
causes minimal disease right so that's
also
kind of an exotic thing which we know
from experience actually works quite
well but the point is the body has a
whole mechanism for dealing with
infections
right so it wouldn't be so strange if
that turned out as crazy as that idea
sounds of attenuated virus to warn the
immune system it wouldn't be so
surprising if the if the body dealt with
that elegantly because it's been dealing
with viruses for
hundreds of millions billions of years
and didn't deal well with hey you've got
a fatty envelope and a
an mrna message that we're going to
hijack your ribosomes with i mean that
that's a whole different ballgame yeah
we're just we're going to
have it stick to a bunch of your extent
cells hope you weren't using them right
right yeah
i'm not sure how to read this one
uh you may have to read it after i read
it out loud because i'm not totally sure
how uh where the how to parse it the top
one religious view
healthy individuals
can defeat any virus
other views
fragile sensitive individuals
are easily manipulated and infected
if continuous tamper and trigger of our
immune system
would it lose its long-term
effectiveness
uh and you can see i was trying to add
in sort of the right i just i can't
quite parse
yeah what's going on so do you read it
as being about physiology rather than
it's not a metaphor for
cognitive viruses
i think the
religious versus other view is a
metaphor for basically medically woke
versus like you know the religion of
those who are who have accepted the
mainstream narrative but that it's
actually a question about um about human
biology about anatomy and physiology i
think but i but honestly i just i can't
quite i can't quite tell what's going on
here yeah well okay
here's what i can say
i don't think it makes sense a view that
a healthy person
is effectively immune to pathogens can't
be right
um healthy people have a great deal of
immunity to pathogens that people who
are compromised in one way or another
do not have so it's not that there isn't
a massive difference between people who
are healthy we know that vitamin d in
particular you know deficiency makes you
vulnerable to all kinds of respiratory
infections in fact
uh a number of people who've said it i
guess it is not ryan cole who said it
first but um that there isn't flu uh
cold and flu season there's vitamin d
deficiency season right that it is that
which is that you know is that exactly
right i don't know but it's certainly
how extraordinary if true yeah it's a
really remarkable and important pattern
because we know that the deficiency is
highly seasonal and that these diseases
are highly seizures and the research
that at least that i've looked at and
that you've looked at a slightly
different body of it looks very
compelling
right now the
i don't think there's any reason to
imagine that people who have no
deficiencies are um perfectly immune to
everything
no right
um are they
are they immune given a certain level of
encounter with almost any pathogen are
they much less likely to actually
contract a disease probably yeah right
some people seem to never get sick
now i've always wondered about these
people is it
a combination of
well-informed immune systems by some
method we had a pediatrician who told us
that he didn't get sick even when kids
were coming into his office sick all the
time because he believed he was
breathing in
enough uh
of these low levels low levels that his
system got warned early and he never
came down with anything now i don't know
old idea that
seems to have lasting power right and so
you know that's a possibility and you
know might explain features of the
sinuses and all
um
it could also be that people who never
seem to get sick have behavioral
patterns that cause them not to
encounter pathogens with the same
regularity right and you
and it could be a combination of things
right and
um i don't know but no i don't think
there's anything to the idea that there
are
people who are basically just immune to
pathogens that
essentially can't be right
it is known that some coping techniques
that serve individuals and childhood
become maladaptive in adulthood is there
an evolutionary or population level
parallel
um yeah
now this
what i would say is the closer you live
to an environment
that doesn't change such that your
ancestors were in a really good
position really well adapted to it
um the less of these kind of uh
violent
midlife course corrections or course
corrections on
maturity will be necessary it's the
discordance between environments that
causes
these
uh these discontinuous shifts
and
so you know yes of course there will be
civilization
level you know you might call them in
fact revolutions or something like that
something where you know the uh the the
paradoxes or
um unfairness of a system builds up to a
level that those who are dependent on it
overthrow it in the hopes of
producing something
better right i mean and that won't be
the the only one i would say
to the extent that we are in such a
phase we're caught between i think an
overwhelming realization that things are
desperately off
but polluted by
those who would shape the narrative to
blame others so that they can continue
to commit the crimes that they are
committing and you know so yeah we have
no agreement over what's gone wrong and
we have maybe useless agreement that
something has gone wrong and it's
causing a kind of incoherent
pre-revolutionary
um boiling over
well that actually feeds right into
the next question here
corruption
and misinformation feel predator
satiation levels of ubiquitous
others likely also feel lost with regard
to where to start
how do we compete with the mainstream
media's perverse form of pre-mastication
as particularly taken with this
phrase pre this word pre-mastication
which
is how
i always used to refer to textbooks
when when we were teaching when we were
college professors and
i think we've said this here before but
the only
the only program that i'd have the only
material that i taught
where i felt that any kind of actual
textbook was warranted was when i did
comparative anatomy as part of my
vertebrate evolution program and i had
students buy the lab manual because
it had you know the right it had
diagrams with actual you know what it
looks like inside sharks and cats to
help guide the dissections that we were
doing
um but in general textbooks
um
are predi or pre-digested is what i
would say but pre-masticate is a is
another fine way to describe it and they
therefore leave a person with a sense
that that's you know that's what is on
the page is true inherently that that
will not change and that that is how
science looks that that is what the
scientific process looks like
usually in biology textbooks you get
some very preliminary pro forma
description of the scientific method
which is the you know
the thing that
we then imagine is how science always
looks and of course as soon as you
actually engage in science you realize
just how non-linear the process tends to
be but you don't learn that from a
textbook and if what you are learning of
say biology is from a textbook
that is what you will come to believe
and frankly people who have learned only
from textbooks who then go on to become
either teachers of science or actual
scientists or medical doctors or medical
professionals of any sort and i would
say most health professionals have
learned almost entirely from textbooks
and presumably their patience i would
hope
uh they are much more likely to assume
that the received wisdom is what is true
and is therefore um how to guide how to
guide treatment and so you know the
mainstream media's perverse form looks
frankly identical to me to what
textbooks have always looked like to me
and why why i issued why i you know
refused to let textbooks into
my classrooms for the most part
except for under very narrowly
prescribed circumstances which is not
exactly an answer but yeah i mean i of
course
share your antipathy for textbooks i
think it's particularly bad in biology
because we're so new to the study of
biology and the textbook has the same
encyclopedic voice that a physics
textbook or chemistry textbook has and
it shouldn't right biology textbooks
should be riddled with you know we have
no idea about yet
um and it just doesn't but
uh the question here corruption and
misinformation feel
uh predator association levels of
ubiquitous yeah i think this is partly
not organic
right presumably your textbook sucks but
not because the people who wrote it
wanted to write a sucky textbook on the
other hand when you have rampant
corruption what you want is people not
to have a coherent response to it right
you want you want you know your your
your opportunity to continue to remain
open
and so
and with misinformation this is even an
easier game to play right because to the
extent that you've got lots of people
colluding in lots of ways and i'm not
alleging anything remarkable there right
yeah board rooms get together and they
collude because it's their fiduciary
responsibility to do so in some sense
um
but
the way you can
destroy opposition to it is with you
know
have truths and
uh
various stories that sound good and then
blow up on investigation you just put
enough of this stuff in and people get
used to oh my god i retweeted that thing
and then i put me in this terrible
position because it turned out that blah
blah blah that i didn't know you know or
i didn't read it to the very last
sentence or whatever it is that causes
that to happen
and
it's
very effective so anyway yeah i don't
think that's an accident is what i'm
saying yep
australia's nt it's going to be northern
territory yeah is it northern
territories
northern territory i think
um australia's nt now can imprison
suspected close covered contacts without
trial
historically what is the most effective
way to respond
well
geez i don't know again
we are lacking
what we have is phenomena
and we know what quadrant of the library
they come from
we don't have anything in that quadrant
of the library that prepares us for this
moment and
you know we have lots of totalitarian
literature
we don't have
turnkey totalitarian literature and
that's where we are
and so i think you know hey
just so happens you and i wrote a book
and the point of that book was you face
novel stuff and we have mechanisms for
dealing with it and those mechanisms
involve us talking to each other about
what we see and what we think it means
and advancing hypotheses and holding
each other's feet to the fire and all of
that and so of course
we're doing that
yeah but i don't i don't think there's a
how do you respond to an x
there's a oh
this has some analogy to these other
things and it has
novel features that don't look like
anything we've seen before and we
shouldn't expect it to converge on one
of these things because for one thing
the technology makes it possible for the
authoritarians to be far more surgical
and far more effective
in surveilling and in disrupting the
opposition
[Music]
sorry you gotta keep talking because i
have to write something down
all right um um okay i'm done now
although now i forgot what i was gonna
say in response to what you were saying
so we're just gonna move on we're gonna
move on yeah
um
indications seem to be that omicron
is producing less severe symptoms are we
approaching the time for coveted parties
how will we know
uh let me say this very clearly
as we said last week
it is possible that omicron could be
good news if it has mild symptoms high
transmissibility and doesn't have any
long-term consequences that we don't
know about i would say it's too early
to say that the first thing is true
though there are indications of mild
symptoms
it is
going to unfortunately be too early to
know anything about the long-term
consequences in other words if these
if any of this
this pandemic results in harms five ten
years out we can't see them from here
and so
that's the thing that ought to have us
hesitant
if it was true
and only if it was true
that this disease at the point you have
gotten past it stops doing damage to you
and we have a variant that is highly
transmissible and not very destructive
then this would in fact be however it
came into the world
would be
effectively the ultimate vaccine
right it would spread itself
it would cause natural immunity to rise
very quickly and it would rid us
of these
incredibly
terrible public health authorities and
their insane plan
for
i i don't even want to say fixing the
world because i don't think that's what
they're doing no they're they're
screwing it up too badly for this to be
simple in aptitude
so
yeah if
it doesn't have a destructive capacity
beyond what we know that in fact it
could as we said last week
save us from these people
um
unfortunately the fly on the ointment is
i don't think we know yeah so it would
require a gamble
yeah
i agree
this next question i'm going to
ask but save for next week and maybe
even move it into the main stream for
next week
i teach college english in prison a
student asked for a list of 12 books he
ought to read over winter break that i
thought were important what were your
respective answers be
so a list of 12 books
that a student of english in prison
might want to read that are important
is a is an intriguing question and a big
question that 12 books is a lot of books
so i'm going to give it a little a
thought a bit of thought good
uh and we'll come back to it either in
the main or the q a next week
what are your thoughts on water birthing
after watching the business of being
born which i have not seen i find the
prospect of hospital births horrifying
to be used only as a last resort love
you both
um
yeah hospital births have medicalized
birth that said birth is um
historically very very hard very
dangerous actually for both mother and
child um but the medicalization has gone
way too far
and has is out too often now about uh
convenience
uh around scheduling and also a response
to the fact that um
many mothers are no longer in the kinds
of shape um that that women ready to
give birth would have been in the past
such that you know sedentary lifestyles
and again obesity make birth uh just
much more challenging uh even than it
would have been in the past that said um
you know even even with that even with
the united states is particularly bad
uh
health record for both men and women um
child mortality
maternal fatality and neonatal fatality
rates are far lower than they've been
historically so uh even with
medicalization of births uh things are
um you know we're still doing some
things right in that regard but i
absolutely agree and i haven't thought
tremendously about it we do have some
friends
who who looked into it a lot and
did water births and it seems
um as long as you
as long as you have the right help like
potentially a really great thing
yeah i would say we're stuck in a bind
my understanding
you tell me if you understand it
differently but my understanding that is
that actually
a hunter-gatherer women do not have a
high rate of death in childbirth
and that in fact modernity has created a
lot of the problem probably through
uh
better nutrition and therefore larger
babies and allometry problems that don't
get corrected by selection i am not sure
i mean i think overall what you said is
true i'm not sure that the first thing
you said is true but i'm not familiar
i'm not up to date on the on what we
think or the mortality data
i i remember that from college it's
possible that something has emerged
since then um but nonetheless that that
was the conclusion is that it is in fact
modernity that makes this so dangerous
and so in effect
the medicalizing of
birth is
um
in part
the
necessitated by
um novel phenomena and then we
over-medicalize it for lots of foolish
business reasons and anyway the point is
that
water birth is probably not
natural
on the other hand could it compensate
for
the novel distortion
that modernity has inflicted on women
and so anyway i'd be really interested
to know if that's in effect what's going
on if it is a novel solution to a novel
hazard
yeah so i'm trying to remember what i
was going to say um
oh if it's if it's true what you said
about
hunter-gatherer mothers um having
relatively low rates of of
fatality during birth during the
birthing process
another reason for that might be and
actually this is just off the top of my
head and it may be you know already well
known not to be true it may already be
willing to be true or it might not be
true at all or it might be new all of
those are possibilities um
but it might be
um that uh women in the weird world
tending to have not just fewer babies
but to start having babies later
means that
um
you know we are simply less elastic and
therefore things are more likely to go
wrong
which would you know would be a result
of you know this kind of hyper novelty
which is
to women's great advantage right you
know having having fewer children later
is absolutely correlated with higher
levels of education with higher levels
of uh life achievement and um you know
in quality of life and you know and a
greater ability to actually care deeply
and fully for the children that you do
have all of this is true so this is not
about like therefore we need to be
having more babies earlier no but one of
the effects might be
um that at the point that you do get
around to having kids um your body is
actually somewhat less capable of doing
so because it hasn't been doing so since
you basically first became
reproductively capable
yep
keep on rocking in the weird world is
the upshot to that
story but i think your analysis is quite
right that the senescent effect just the
simple fact that we are all less capable
of healing and less capable of dealing
with insult the older we are past
reproductive maturity and a body that
just hasn't had iterative experiences
doing it and now being asked to you know
in my case a few days shy of my 35th
birthday for the first time it's like
well that's that's got to be harder on a
body you know not just than on like a 17
year old body but then on a body that's
you know older but has done it a few
times and has been ex you know has has
you know expanded and retracted in the
ways that it needs to so yep yeah
why do you think some states have less
buy-in to the narrative than others
oh i think this is just an amplifier
effect
um what do you mean by that which is to
say that
um
[Music]
well if we can
go back to what we were talking about
earlier
people are built to census what those
around them
see and imagine
and to the extent
that
anything
causes you to get a
biased sample
it will cause you to default faster in
that direction so the point is what is
your
um
basic
uh starting point your your priors for
the likelihood that um
you know
removing
freedoms from you to
fix your health is a good idea
right and now you just look at red
states and blue states and how do people
answer this question and so the point is
if you're a blue person you're much more
likely to be in a blue state and what
does that mean it means you'd be
surrounded by other blue people and
that's going to amplify your sense that
this is wisdom right
and
the online platform
positive feedback positive feedback is
exactly okay yeah
um so that positive feedback thing is
then going to be hyper novelly augmented
by
the um
you know we used to call the tv the
idiot box i'm not sure what the analog
for a computer in which some algorithmic
monster behind the scenes is deciding
what you ought to see based on
some priorities it has
iai
what's the i uh idiot artificial
intelligence
yeah it's artificial idiocy is is more
or less what it is but but the point is
if that thing is also you know
building a model and it discovers that
you know you have a red a red state of
mind and it starts feeding you things
that a red state of mind will feel at
home with or
right the point is all of these things
are amplifiers and nobody ever figured
out what to do about novel amplifiers
because you're not supposed to be facing
them right
according to
up-to-date and i don't know
i don't know that source according to
up-to-date ssris need to be tapered even
after only one to three weeks of use
especially fluvoxamine because of its
very short half-life
i feel like that should say it's very
long half-life
wouldn't the longer half-life
i'm not sure i would expect
well why would the length of half-life
be related to a
higher or lower need for tapering i got
it but i don't think it's not a complete
analysis but imagine that something had
an extremely long half-life right then
it effectively tapers itself
right you stop taking it and the point
is oh okay it tapers if it has a very
short half-life okay so you have to
behaviorally taper right if the
chemistry if the of the
if the biochemistry of the thing in your
body doesn't taper for you right now i
did read i saw i wish i could remember
who it was but somebody was reporting
their own recovery from covid
and they used flavoxamine it was the
thing that they credited their very
quick recovery to and they make the
point which i think steve kirsh has also
made this point frequently that one of
the reasons that those of us who fear
ssris should maybe not fear the use of
fluvoxamine for covid is that the dose
is actually
way lower than it would be for the
treatment of a mood disorder
yeah
you know i haven't looked into it a lot
but i gotta say i have the same
[Music]
i have the same immediate like honestly
visceral reaction at this point um to
fluvoxamine as i do to the mrna vaccines
it's like
um well i don't i don't have that
reaction because
they are
as far as we know
ephemeral and even to the extent that
they have greater effects that you
understand uh flavoxamine well but i
mean precisely not maybe given given the
you know the long-term effects that some
people who've been on them who cannot
get back to normal
uh experience well but we're talking
about a extremely short treatment with
apparently a low dose and so
i think the thing is to me that's not in
the same ballpark as a
novel transfection with an agent that
then permanently reprograms your immune
system at a minimum the permanent
reprogramming of the immune system is
certainly different
the uh
who knows for how long it will last
effective reprogramming of your
synaptic connections
seems uh
rather dramatic as well
believe me i have the same initial
reaction which is why would you use this
when we have other things that don't
have these kinds of side effects that
appear
and just risks i mean i feel like it
feels similar to me in part because
it would appear we obviously don't have
long-term data on the mrna vaccines but
it would appear that some number of
people who get vaccinated are just fine
yep right and
um
we do have longer term data for the
ssris and it would appear that you know
not nearly as many people who are on
them at least you know the longer you're
on the higher the dose all of this the
worse it is um but that you know
relatively small fraction of people who
are on those things are just fine after
a while and it's you know it is it does
seem to be reversible for some people um
but for a lot of people no matter how
hard they try they don't seem to be able
to reverse it right but
i mean we're going to go around in
circles my sense is
the evidence that is spooky does not
come from very short-term low-dose use
and the expectation would be
that the effect would be
quite a bit diminished so look this is
the first thing that i said when i heard
fluvoxamine worked which is
i'm willing to believe that it does but
that i can't imagine why we would go to
that step when we have things that don't
have serious side effects so it's not
that i don't get it but now and again
it's you know
i i guess i prefer
i guess i like the languaging of adverse
events
uh for the vaccines rather than side
effects and i i feel like i'm talking
with regard to fluvoxamine and the other
ssris adverse events
um that you know yes seem to be you know
side effects ish but then you know
persist for so long how you have so many
things that are associated with them um
even you know beyond the taking of the
thing that it's it's more of okay you
just you had an adverse reaction to the
thing
and you know maybe this is just semantic
but to me it feels like a more holistic
understanding of of the risk to talk
about adverse events rather than side
effects for these two classes of
pharmaceuticals as corrupt as we know
these
pharma companies that are making these
vaccines to be
would they ever view the human immune
system as their greatest enemy to their
great empire
um my guess
is they would not ever consciously
understand their enemy to be the immune
system but
that they have a you know dozens of
rationalizations
yeah that caused them to
see certain kinds of
of uh therapies as promising and others
as really not as promising as they might
seem on first pass and all of that and
it just so happens to result in a
program that you know treats disease and
fails to cure it and
you know
thinks that the newfangled drug whose
side effects we know nothing about is
inherently better than the old drug that
doesn't seem to have very many and you
know that those biases would fall out of
some complex network of rationalizations
yep
um we are asked
to
consider this
zack you can show my
screen uh
it's an abstract published in the
journal circulation
but it's just
it's just
the abstract
and it has associated with it an
expression of concern
um
which
all it says is expression of concern so
the other is there is there a question
or just consider it yeah what do you
think of this
um
mrna code and vaccines dramatically
increase endothelial inflammatory
markers and acs risk as measured by the
pols cardiac test
a warning
i read it
i also read so there is no paper
associated with it right i can't find
one right so when you say you read it
you read the abstract i'm not familiar
with circulation so i don't know if it's
normal for them to publish an abstract
without a paper i assume it must be in
some regard i don't know if that means
that somebody gave a paper at a
conference and this is the abstract or
what
but i can say
i find the warning bizarre yeah i don't
think there's anything strange about
this abstract and the warning complains
about certain things that aren't in the
abstract that the abstract doesn't claim
are in the abstract oh so i don't see a
warning beyond what i clicked here
um so you can click through
a couple of clicks into that warning
the warning is just that long yeah but
they published a
separate thing that looks oh see okay so
zach you can show this
um you want to read it this article
expresses concern regarding the abstract
et cetera et cetera
which originally was published november
8th
soon after publication of the above
abstract in circulation it was brought
to the american heart association
committee on scientific session programs
attention that there are potential
errors in the abstract specifically
there are several typographical errors
yep
there is no data in the abstract
regarding myocardial t-cell infiltration
there are no statistical analyses for
significance provided and the author is
not clear that only anecdotal data was
used
we are publishing this expression of
concern until a suitable correction is
published to indicate the abstract in
its current version may not be reliable
um
so this strikes me as highly unusual
that warning appears to imply that it
was a the abstract of a so-called paper
so for those who are not oh i read it
the opposite way i read it as this is
just an abstract well but it says that
it was brought to the committee on
i forget what their language was yeah
but they said the abstract was brought
they don't say the paper was brought
um
soon soon after publication of the above
abstract in circulation it was brought
to the american heart association
committee committee of
on scientific session programs attention
scientific session program so i think
what they're saying is they publish the
abstract of a session that is to say a
conference session
and so this was a paper delivered as a
speech
and they have published the abstract we
don't have access to the speech
i don't know that that's what one should
infer but it's what i would infer
in in any case
the complaint is highly unusual first of
all what is suggested in here and i
believe you know i can't see the work
but what is suggested appears
straightforward which is that they
measured these biomarkers for
inflammation before and after
vaccination and they found
large increases in
the
these markers okay that doesn't say what
the consequence of it is
so i mean also i i had read this but
it's it's i mean it came out almost a
month ago um so
among other things in this it says a
total of 566 patients aged 28 to 97 male
to female ratio one to one seen a
preventive cardiology practice had a new
pols test drawn from two to ten weeks
following the second coveted shot and
was compared to the previous
but the expression of concern is that
the data are anecdotal
right i don't i don't see
what in here
suggests that these data are anecdotal i
don't either i don't think
typographical errors is such an absurd
you obviously don't pull an abstract for
typographical errors you go in and fix
the comments i think what we can infer
is something but
but an actual complaint an actual
scientific complaint it's anecdotal data
they didn't say that oh well hey you
should just fix that in the abstract if
that's true but i don't i don't see even
if what was done
you know the the expression of concern
doesn't say they didn't do what they
said they did it says among other things
it was anecdotal and i'm looking at this
going i don't if they did what they said
they did i don't see how that can be
anecdotal well it may be a highly
technical use of the word anecdotal
because to the extent that um you know
maybe they didn't intend to study this
and these
blood draws were done and these markers
were assessed then somebody said hey i
wonder right okay so that's not
hypothesis driven but as you well know
that's how like the vast majority of
science is published is done now it
pretends some of it pretends to be
hypothesis driven most of it doesn't
even
[ __ ] care you don't hear me defending
that warning i think that warning is a
continuation of the pattern that we saw
with rose and mccullough where some
highly unusual academic demon has shown
up and done some highly unusual thing
because these facts are unforgivable
yeah right and so that thing keeps
telling us that hey a scientist doing
scientific work and this is you know
preliminary work but then unless it says
something it tells you what it says it
tells you how they came about the
information it's all very normal which
also incidentally if if you're right and
i also read academic sessions as an
indication that this is
an abstract which is a summary of a
paper that was presented at a conference
this is what conferences are for this is
like this is what conferences are
supposed to be for this is where people
with similar research interests get
together and share with each other
preliminary preliminary findings or
findings that are about to be published
or in some cases that have already been
published but mostly this is the place
where all of the experts in some
particular domain get together and
expose ideas to one another and hash
things out so the idea that a research
abstract especially if it's from a talk
at a conference
is you know not highly refined enough is
an absurd critique because that's
exactly what they're supposed to be
about right i mean not not that you know
not that we prefer it when they're not
refined or when they're preliminary but
like that's what conferences are that's
what they are and in this case there is
a proper response if you think there's
something wrong with this beyond typos
which is that you you
write your own paper and it says here's
why that doesn't mean what you think it
does
right and the point is instead what they
did is they went to the teacher
and they tattled and their tattle
involves typos
right and you know
the point is it's nonsense
why are we seeing nonsense in this place
well everything surrounding covet is
abnormal right you're not allowed to do
normal science you're not allowed to do
normal medicine you're not allowed to
have your own opinion you're not allowed
to decide whether or not
treatments that are ineffective are
actually something you want or don't
want all of the rules have been changed
around covet and that's the problem yes
okay i think we're at an hour uh
two more quick questions will your
podcast be available in spanish at some
point um i don't know about translation
we've been asked that before i think it
would be useful to have it in spanish
for sure uh the book's gonna be in
spanish as well as lithuanian and other
languages um but uh we don't have any
immediate
plans because
we have too many other immediate plans
that we are trying to make sure
uh keep happening if there's a future
but we would love for that to happen and
spanish should certainly be the first
language that um we would we would
hope for uh translation services
in yep
uh and and you are not the first person
to ask
and then finally let's go with
this from sally what happens to natural
immunity when the vaccine is introduced
into the body
what happens to natural so first of all
we have to separate between innate and
natural immunity so natural immunity
refers to immunity derived from
infection
and so the question is what happens to
the immunity that a recovered person has
had when you introduce the vaccine now
early you have to call those persons of
recovery
i'm sorry
i don't know what we have to do next but
i'm not complying um good
the problem is so
i pointed out
i don't know how when the vaccines first
showed up
there were all kinds of concerns that
weren't really addressed right one of
them is
just imagine the cartoon version of the
immune system okay a cartoon version of
the immune system encounters
covid
it mounts a response it
defeats covid and it leaves the person
with a memory library of responses to
covet okay then you introduce one of
these vaccines or so-called vaccines
that vaccine triggers the production of
spike protein by one's own cells
now you have spike protein in a system
that has already been warned about
pathogens wearing spike protein
right and so one of the things that may
likely happen and one of the reasons
that you may find that there is an
increase in vulnerability
right after you've been vaccinated is
that what you've done is you've dumped
spike protein into a system that
remembers spike protein and you've
occupied that fraction of the immune
system that was aware of this thing and
so now if something comes in wearing
spike protein it doesn't signal an alarm
it doesn't get special attention right
so anyway that's one thing that may
happen
um there's another thing
uh it's a little hard to see maybe it
doesn't have a negative consequence but
there's this thing called original
antigenic sin which is basically a
translation for once
you know how once you've encountered a
something that
thing
then informs your visual system so
you're more likely to see that thing
again
well the immune system is like this in
the sense that once it's been taken down
a particular road it has a hard time
finding its way back and taking a
different road and so in this case
it is possible that there's some
slightly different reaction to the
vaccines is that harmful i don't know
it's much more likely to be harmful in
the other direction if a naive immune
system
encounters the vaccines and gets for
example hyper focused on spike protein
which is maybe not the best way to fight
a
complex pathogen right then it may get
hyper focused on spike protein if the
pathogen shows up and so what you've
done is you've misinformed the immune
system or poorly informed it and that
means that the excellent response that
recovered people have won't have been
had by people who've been vaccinated
first so anyway the answer is we don't
know but
um we don't know but welcome to complex
systems there are lots of things in play
here and that's part of the problem
indeed
all right i think we are i think we've
reached the end we've reached the end
and we are so far north that is
beginning to get dark outside uh it's
just wow it really is i mean we're also
in the trees uh that that has not
changed since we began live streaming
today no the trees wow
but it's a little taller it's december
so not much yes right yeah
um growth rings show us that for sure
right
totally yeah okay um
we will be back next week
same place different time four hours
earlier i think is when we'll be
starting next week uh in the meantime
consider um
getting some direwolves your epic tabby
or you know digital book burning stuff
at the store join us at our patreons go
check out natural
selections and
lots of other things i've forgotten to
mention i'm sure darkhorsemoderator
gmail.com can answer your logistical
questions
and until next time be good to the ones
you love eat good food and get outside
consider sneering at an authoritarian
politely well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you